So today I'm here
to talk to you about babies
and their understanding of the world.
Specifically, their understanding
of dangerous situations.
But first, in case you haven't interacted
with a baby recently,
here are some clips of what we call
typical one-year-old behavior.
Well, from this, you might think
that babies don't understand anything
about dangerous situations.
Or maybe they don't understand
anything about anything.
But today, I'm going to tell you
five surprising things
that I learned while I did this work.
The first surprise is that babies
are really willing to do dangerous things.
So these are videos captured in the lab.
And the finding from this work
is that one-year-old babies
are perfectly willing to walk off the edge
of these steep drop offs
without even thinking twice.
And in fact, they need months
of experience learning to walk
before they start to show any signs
of fear in these situations.
So that was what I completed
before I started my PhD.
And so I looked at these
findings and I thought,
Really? Is it really true that babies
are oblivious to danger?
Or could we figure out another way
to study this question?
So the history of developmental psychology
tells us that if we study babies
by measuring complex behaviors,
we might miss out on hidden truths
about their minds.
So what should we do instead?
Well, another way is,
we can ask them what they think
when other people are put
into the same situation.
From the first months of life,
babies have expectations about the world,
that objects are solid
and don't float in mid-air,
that people have intentions and goals.
And their expectations are often clearest
when they themselves
are looking at the events
rather than participating in them.
So that's going to be surprise number two.
If you test babies at the same age
as I just showed you,
in the second way,
you see a completely different
pattern of results.
So, here is an example
of one of our stimuli.
And babies are going to see someone else,
this red guy in the middle,
face choice: to jump left or jump right.
Now intuitively, you can recognize
that one of these choices
is more dangerous than the other.
Falling in the ditch on the left
would be a lot worse.
So all else being equal, maybe
this red guy is going to go right.
And the question for babies was:
can they make that distinction,
and do they have that same expectation?
So here we're measuring how long babies
look at each of these outcomes.
And the simple logic of this
measure is that babies,
and indeed people of all ages,
tend to pay more attention
to what's surprising.
In this case, when the red guy
does the more dangerous thing.
So here's what we found.
I'm plotting looking time on seconds
on the vertical axis
and in red is the average looking
when babies saw the more
dangerous choice, in green,
and the safer choice, in pink.
So indeed, they look longer when someone
chooses a dangerous thing
over a safe thing.
But in contrast, the very same babies
responded completely differently
when they saw these very,
very similar control videos
with the same obstacles,
except this time there are
no characters in the scene,
so there's no danger at all.
And this suggests that they're not
responding to the obstacles themselves,
and they're actually really
responding to the danger
that's imposed by the obstacles.
So that's the second surprise.
Babies do understand something
about dangerous situations,
but remember, based
on their own choices, this is shocking.
We wouldn't expect a one-year-old
to care about the distinction
between a deep versus
a shallow drop at all.
But measured in this way, babies
are making exactly that distinction
when someone else faces the same choice.
So surprise number three
is that this finding generalizes
regardless of whether babies are tested
in sterile lab environments like this,
an empty room with nothing else
but our videos to look at
and cluttered home environments.
So in the middle of this work, COVID hit
and developmental psychologists
everywhere scrambled to figure out
whether data collection was even possible.
If you ask me, I would have
predicted definitely not.
There's a reason that we conduct
studies in the lab.
Our movies can be projected
to these huge screens,
we can minimize distraction,
we can get highly precise,
high-definition videos
of where the babies are looking.
But we figured we had to try.
So after a long process of figuring out
exactly how to do this,
we ended up calling,
video calling families at home,
and they played the same movies
for babies on their laptop screens.
And we measured their looking
behaviors just like before.
So let's just pause and take stock of all
the differences between these two setups.
In many ways, this was doomed to fail.
I certainly thought it was going to fail,
but that's not what happened.
So on the left are the results
I just showed you,
with babies tested in the lab,
and on the right is the same
experiment we repeated
in a new group of babies tested at home.
And as you can see, the main results
look remarkably similar.
So that was surprise number three.
This finding is similar regardless
of whether babies are tested in the lab
or at home.
So I just want to pause
and state how non-trivial
and actually really groundbreaking
this was for my field.
My prediction, that we cannot study babies
using these measures at home,
wasn't true at all.
And during this process,
we learned not only that these
studies can work at all,
but that they can actually
work really well.
And at the end of the day, this process
was just easier and faster for everyone.
So we ended up being able to collect
video data faster than ever before,
which actually required us to engineer
new tools for processing the data.
So here I'm showing you a tool we built
that can find a baby's face,
given a webcam of their study
and detect where they're looking
as good as a human can,
that is robust, even for these very fuzzy,
low-quality webcam videos.
So this whole experience
was amazing for our team.
And for me, this experience
is its own achievement.
It took families and scientists
working together
to figure out how to study baby minds
in a changing world.
So that was surprise number four.
The pandemic, rather than delaying
and maybe ending the work in my field,
actually accelerated it.
I never would have tried online research
had COVID not happened,
but now that we've tried it,
it's vastly expanded
the reach of our work.
These tools enable us to study babies
anywhere in the world
with an internet connection.
It lets us work with families
of varying demographics,
and it lets us more easily access
clinical populations
that can be harder to reach.
So the last surprise,
surprise number five.
All along I've been telling you
that babies look longer
when someone chooses a dangerous action
or are willing to do
really dangerous things,
when I probably should
have said "on average."
On average,
the babies we tested look longer at X,
on average, babies are willing to do Y.
So to illustrate this point,
here are the same graphs
I showed you before,
but hidden in these graphs,
and in all the data sets from my field,
are vast individual differences.
So now I've added back all the raw data
that you didn't see before.
Now each pair of points is a baby.
And as you can see, there's striking
variability between babies
that average out to an effect.
Now to be clear,
I don't think this undermines
the conclusion of the work.
The key prediction
is that at home and in the lab,
babies are sensitive to something
about these dangerous situations.
But one remaining puzzle from my field
is what these individual differences mean.
So one answer is, that's just
measurement noise.
We're studying babies,
they can't follow directions,
they have short attention spans,
they're free to basically look
as long as they want.
So maybe these differences
don't mean anything.
It's just random noise.
A second answer is that part of these
differences is driven by external factors.
So maybe, for our online sample,
the babies who showed the biggest effects
had the biggest screens to look at,
or maybe the clearest
internet connections.
And the third answer, maybe the one
that's the most interesting,
is that these differences
reflect something that's true
about the actual differences
between these babies.
So for example, suppose that we put babies
from this looking time study
in the physical situations
that I showed you
from the beginning of the talk.
Remember, there are individual differences
in those experiments too.
So a question could be, would the babies
who show the strongest effects here
be the ones who also
are more likely to be afraid
and avoid doing the dangerous
things themselves?
And similarly, are the babies
who do not show an effect here
the ones that are willing to kind of
boldly plunge into the abyss?
So to be clear, I don't know
which one of these answers is right,
but I think it's important to show
this variability in our papers
and to study them.
So I think that these challenges
are actually tractable,
in part because of the tools
that were delivered by the pandemic.
So stay tuned and maybe
I'll have an answer for you
next time we see each other.
So that's the last surprise,
certainly a surprise for me,
who started out looking at bar
plots of average behaviors
and assuming that most babies
behave the same.
Instead, there's variability
in human development
on just about any measure we can make,
on just about any topic we can study,
from physical understanding
to language learning.
And making sense
of these individual differences,
telling apart the signal from the noise,
continues to be a challenge
and an opportunity for my field.
So the next time you look
into the eyes of a baby,
know that there's way more
going on in their minds and brains
than you might think.
So, zooming out to the big picture,
let's think about what
these findings tell us
about the origins of the mind.
So to me, these findings,
and many other findings from our field,
tell us that babies have
abstract knowledge
about the social and the physical world.
They can perceive and reason about events
that they've never seen before,
like these stimuli,
they can represent not only what happened
but what could happen next,
or maybe what could
have happened but didn't.
And early in development, babies
are learning to solve these two
really, really hard problems.
The first problem of connecting
other people's actions
to their physical situations
and hidden mental states.
And also the second hard problem
of figuring out how to act in the world
given what they know.
So of course, that's both
an interpretation and a hypothesis.
We have a lot to learn about these
profoundly intelligent minds.
And actually, the magic of that process
reminds me a lot of a one-year-old.
Falling over, having a long look
at the obstacles before us
and then taking a big leap.
Thank you.
(Applause)